they it showed that i had um
had a non-displaced
fracture
in my wrist and it was like it was small
but it was still still yeah like a
non-displaced chip so like i chipped a
bone but it didn't like
leave the surface right um but it has
shown that the bone that grew over it so
it healed but it was still pain i was
still in pain because i kept getting it
hit or falling on it
um so like i guess i played with like
somewhat of a fracture for for like two
months um wow and then in the playoffs
there was a play against against
milwaukee in game three
i dunked it giannis chased me down and
he fouled me and i fell into
the um to like the crowd and that was
the most painful it's been since
that day um that i heard it and i ended
up getting a cortisone shot in my wrists
that night and you could see it
yeah it's like much lighter i've lost
like color in my hand because it kills
the fat cells and there's not a lot of
fat in my hand so like i've lost color
right there
but you know after each game i would
have to like wear a brace
you know to shoot around and i would
take it off before the camera saw me and
then
you know pre-game taking my nap but i
have to put it back on you know just to
make sure it was stable so no one knew
you were dealing with this injury
besides like internally yeah it saw the
team yeah but it's like in my mind if i
if i'm going out there to play it's like
nothing matters like